dernier briefing avant le grand saut
cette équipe spécialisée dans les
interventions au perche et se prépare à
une centaine de mètres au dessus du
niveau de la mer à cette hauteur
absolument rien n'est laissé au hasard
un premier temps on essaie de trouver un
point irréprochable at il pour mettre
nos cordes
donc on a une corde de sécurité une cure
de travail faut pas avoir peur du vide
l'appréhension l'a toujours dit pas
forcément du vide
on a toujours l'appréhension mais je
pense qu'à partager mon père
l'appréhension à comprendre autrement
car arrive le moment le plus délicat du
chantier verticale le passage des
technicien cordiste au dessus du vide
bluff ou pour réfléchir fera voir tout
le matériel nécessaire parce qu'en
général quand une au milieu ça devient
compliqué
changement de cordes donc on s'assure
toujours être sûr de cordes en même
temps donc là il fait son changement de
carte justement pour semer dans son axe
de travail de façon à être positionné
pour à travailler à terre un troisième
technicien assure la transmission du
matériel aux ouvriers monte en l'air
c'est le martiniquais de l'étape
dans le jargon on l'appelle le piéton
quand écologie ça y est je le donne
toute la technicité du matériel à poser
et quand ils posent chaque élément qu'il
pose on est en symbiose et en
coordination pour le matériel soit bien
posé que le matériel arrive yens bien
acheminé en eau des efforts déployés
afin d'offrir un véritable habillage de
lumière à la tour lu mina une matrice
l'aide de 5 mm va nous permettre
d'afficher des caractères des lignes
lumineuses différentes et d'avoir des
effets
des effets eux
scénique sur la sur la tour en même
temps que ce qui sera diffusé sur
l'écran
l'ancien cordistes dirige les opérations
christophe a monté son entreprise face à
la demande grandissante pour ce type
d'intervention on a aussi bien dépeinte
comme des maçons comme des profils
complètement industriels pour nettoyer
aussi bien dans des silos que pour faire
la peinture de charpente également du
ravalement de façade donc aujourd'hui on
a appelé pour divers métiers par rapport
au coût moins onéreux et plus rapide
le résultat devrait être visible de très
loin à la nuit tombée et ce dès les
premiers jours gras du carnaval 2019